um yeah it when I started having muscle  spasms and my throat felt like it was  gonna close The Voice alum Megan Lindsey  tells ET everything about the aftermath  of being bit on the face by a brown  recluse spider weeks of scary moments  and serious healing what are they saying  about about the scar about the  permanence um it's it's hard to tell I'm  only two months out so they say like you  really should wait six months to a year  to see how how it heals and then you can  decide if you want to do something else  to to help it the venom didn't affect me  singing at all which is awesome which  actually my wound care doctor was a  little bit worried about that hear more  from Megan who's now turning her focus  back to touring and her new record  tonight I'm the teeth